we have a clip but before we get to that
I wanted to talk about it's the final
season yeah it's sad man and you
everyone takes something from the set
and I'm told that you took Garry's he
has this bag that he cares he's the bag
man you have to have everything yes or
Selina Meyers character yes available at
all times and available at all times and
he has his leather bag and they asked me
what I would want to take and I wanted
to take that because it's like he always
had it and I touch and it's kind of a
nice sense memory of motion so we have
that are you going to keep that
someplace special if we have a picture
of it so captures here it also feels
like it's weighing you down it's filled
with the stones with you what would you
what would you take from your set what's
that what would you take I would take
Andy I would just have you wrapped up
and put him in a warehouse or I can keep
him all right we have a clip from veep
anything you need to tell us about this
clip last time I did the worst setup
with the Arrested Development clip I
think it was not good look at your last
appearance cuz it sounds like a disaster
the way you're describing it yeah it was
it was pretty all over the place but it
was like I was I didn't I don't think I
have a good setup for this one which one
is this again the hell you asking me for
you want me to get the word out on any
one of the audience want to pitch in and
it possible is this the fan OHS has just
arrived yeah I don't remember I don't
know we're getting ready for something
oh this is the worst setup I've heard
I've been doing this a long time roll it
just roll it just roll it let me see
which one it is man this is not a big
deal just show them your birth
certificate while we're at it why don't
we show my estrogen patch prescription
and a Polaroid of my stretch marks may
your wisdom strange I have always been
open and transparent about how old I am
yes
55 I'm believing
53 late forties you're all correct well
look who cleans up nice can I get a
quick fiver madam P yeah
Oh Gary mm that reminds me I need to
switch out my estrogen patch should I
slip in a little swirl up a guest room
you can surprise me yeah oh I like Gary
Collin stretchmarks wisdom straight yes
yes ed you're always muttering these
along I mean pretty much wants to be
married to Selina yeah but he can't
marry her cuz she's God he can only
worship her
oh oh that's a lot of thought about your
character thank you yeah I just show up
and sick I'd show up and say the lines
that's what I do
and never ask a question I have to say
I'm gonna miss that show I am gonna miss
we also like each other a whole lot like
it's really fun the cast seems like they
you're like what's that like what why
don't you ask Andy what he thinks it's
like because we're not talking no but we
have a really good time so it's a bummer
man you kind of say goodbye to something
that was really special
yeah I can imagine